this video is sponsored by the
Rijksmuseum they've got a really awesome
youtube series called is this art that
is very wise cracky so stick around to
the end to hear more hey wise crack
Jared again if memes are anything to go
by it seems like the Star Wars prequels
have gone through a resurgence and
popularity since their initial critical
pounding so that leads us to wonder were
we all wrong did we misjudge what are in
fact cinema classics
I don't like sound probably not but it
wasn't for lack of trying as we talked
about in our what went wrong on the
Phantom Menace George Lucas had some
pretty grand ambitions now in Attack of
the Clones Lucas had epic ambitions like
to create an actual epic romance in the
style of classics like gone with the
wind or Cleopatra he even used one
particular romantic movie from the 1960s
as a template but did Lucas succeed in
his ambitions well not quite but if we
dive into his original inspiration we
can discover how the story of a spoiled
brat it's not fair dating a patronizing
princess and he'll always be that little
boy I knew on Tatooine went so horribly
wrong welcome to this wisecrack edition
on Star Wars Episode two what went wrong
and of course spoilers ahead if you
really care about Star Wars prequels
spoilers it might have been a while
since you last saw this movie so here's
a quick recap set over a decade after
The Phantom Menace Attack of the Clones
follows eight now sort of grown-up
Anakin Skywalker who is charged with
protecting the once queen now senator
Padme Amidala from multiple
assassination attempts after staying in
a variety of romantic locations wouldn't
you know it they fall in love
meanwhile obi-wan discovers that an army
of clones has been created for the
Republic from this he uncovers a
separatist plot to start a civil war led
by former Jedi Count Dooku but gets
captured after finding his mother dead
and performing a casual massacre Anakin
steals a droid and goes with Padme to
rescue obi-wan they get captured too and
are sent to an arena to die with obi-wan
good job there's some stuff about Jar
Jar causing the downfall of society
that the Senate emergency powers to the
Supreme Chancellor goddamnit Jar Jar
then it's your usual last forty minute
extravaganza of lightsabers and
explosions as Jedi's and the clone army
battled the bad men it turns out the war
was all because of the dark side as
usual everything is going as planned and
Padme Anakin get married despite them
both knowing it's a bad idea who her
destroyers episode 2 continues Lucas's
attempt to answer the question how does
democracy slide into fascism and to his
credit he does this in a really smart
way by taking inspiration from history
and contemporary politics the film opens
with a bombing attempt to kill Padme
which sets all the events of the film in
motion and by the end has led to a war
begun the clone Lukas seems to be
invoking the assassination of Archduke
Franz Ferdinand which is often cited as
the catalyst for world war 1 the film
was released not even a year after the
9/11 attacks that would then lead to the
invasion of Iraq and here we have a
blockbuster popcorn movie written before
all that happened providing some
prescient commentary Count Dooku and
Darth Sidious manufacture a conflict for
their own ends the threat of Dooku's
droid army allows Palpatine to gain
emergency powers and control the Clone
Army kind of like how Hitler was made
Chancellor of Germany in January of 1933
by manufacturing conflict and a
Bolshevik conspiracy against the state
he was granted dictatorial powers by the
Reichstag in March of the same year and
well we all know how that turned out
the movies also interested in showing
how choice is made with even the best
intentions can be manipulated into
benefiting the wrong people the Camino
uns were simply hired to create an army
they didn't know that the guy who placed
the order was actually dead Master
sifo-dyas was killed almost 10 years ago
they also didn't know that they were
building the stormtroopers that would
eventually oppress an entire galaxy even
poor old Jar Jar thinks he's doing what
Padme would have wanted when he presents
the motion to grant Palpatine emergency
powers if only senator Amidala again
Lucas is drawing from history you can
trace this kind of manipulation back to
events like the Munich Agreement at the
time this was considered a way of
preventing war by appeasing Hitler's
demand for more territory of course it
didn't work it was a deal struck with
good intentions but turned out to be a
major step towards war Jar Jar Binks and
Neville Chamberlain he applied yourself
now while this analysis of
socio-political history is going on
Lucas had the smart idea of using a
character drama at the center of the
movie to highlight the personal side of
the larger conflict how does he do that
he makes it a love story of course a
love story against the backdrop of a war
whether it's Romeo and Juliet Robin Hood
and Maid Marian or neo and Trinity love
in a time of conflict is a story that's
as old as drama itself but Lucas seems
to have settled on one specific movie
influence for his doomed lovers the 1965
romantic epic dr. Zhivago an adaptation
of the Boris Pasternak novel dr. Zhivago
is the story of doctor and poet Yuri
Zhivago whose life and love for a
married woman is dramatically changed by
the conflicts of the First World War the
Russian Revolution and the Russian Civil
War it explores in detail the historical
context and puts him in his beloved Lara
Antep OVA right at the center of that
conflict sound familiar
from the themes to the posters which
Lucas specifically asked artists Drew
Struzan to imitate the two movies have a
lot in common both Asha bago and Anakin
are taken from their families at a young
age and both bury their mothers on
screen both stories are set at a time of
burgeoning civil war episode 2 shows the
events leading up to the clone war while
Zhivago depicts the events leading to
the Russian Revolution the romance
central to both movies is forbidden by
social expectations or class Anakin's
role as a Jedi forbids him from love
passions whereas you BA go and Laura's
pre-existing marriages hinder their love
Javad oh the wealthy Tania and Lara to
the Bolshevik commander strelnikov both
films even depict our main characters
forced to travel as refugees the biggest
similarity is in how both films depict
the devastating consequences true love
can have love acts as a corrupting
influence on Anakin whether it's him
disobeying orders to find his mother and
going psycho when she dies or how he
believes his and Padme love could be
hidden they could keep it a secret the
strength of Anakin's love causes him to
do some stupid sinister and downright
evil things while it doesn't go to the
same extreme dr. Zhivago depicts a good
man who heals the sick driven to
breaking small laws like stealing
firewood to provide for his family and
then driven to lie and cheat on that
family because of his love for Lara
shavoo goes love for Lara results in him
abandoning his wife and children but by
the end said love makes him abandon Lara
and his unborn child as well to save
them from persecution Anakin's love for
Padme by contrast results in the death
of thousands of Jedi and the creation of
a fascist Galactic Empire which seems a
little like overkill to me
so if attack of the clones is cribbing
so closely from one of the great love
stories of all time why is it such a dud
sure there's the toe curling Lee bad
dialogue I don't like Sam and the total
lack of chemistry between Anakin and
Padme but all of that might have been
okay if it wasn't for the fact that
Lucas missed the mark on how the
politics and love story of dr. Zhivago
are integrated dr. Zhivago succeeds
because the romantic leads have
conflicting loyalties but are willing to
forego them for the sake of love and
their shared compassion for others
Javad go and Lara are seen together
several times in the first hour of the
movie but don't actually come together
until something happens that reveals
their shared desire to help the injured
are you a nut
they then both end up working closely
together in a field hospital where sure
enough they fall in love the factory
bago and Lara forgo their respective
loyalties out of a desire to help then
fall in love because of that encapsulate
how well the political backdrop
and love story are integrated attack of
the clones by contrast pushes Anakin and
Padme together with forces outside of
their control
Palpatine suggests obi-wan and Anakin
protect Padme then the jedi council
orders anakin to protect Padme alone in
the conveniently romantic setting of
Naboo
none of these actions are their choice
senator Amidala will not refuse an
executive oda Padme Anakin are forced
together by the political conflict as
opposed to being drawn to one another by
their feelings about the conflict this
is the same problem we mentioned in our
episode 1 video the characters are
metaphorical paper boats being carried
along by the current of the plot they
have no agency whereas Java goes arc is
all about the choices he makes near the
beginning he is supportive of the
Bolshevik protests justice equality and
bread and then sees their slaughter in
the square by the cossacks but later his
house is taken by the communist state
he's forced to lie about the existence
of typhus and starvation in the capital
your family listening to rumour mongers
prominent that is no typhus in our city
and is even forced to flee with his
family because he now disagrees with the
party's policies
Javaris loyalties change over the course
of the movie and his choices reflect
that his choice to find Lora and be with
her at the end of the film is motivated
by the events of the film instead of
being railroaded into one way of life by
the changing political landscape he
chooses to be with Lara no paper boats
there episode 2 on the other hand offers
no such character arc or agency
Anakin starts as a disobedient brat and
you will pay attention to my lead
why what an ends as a disobedient brat
I'll take them together
he starts off with an unrequited love
for Padme and ends with a required love
because reasons we never hear his
opinion on the conflict only his pretty
suspect opinions on the running of the
Republic the trouble is that people
don't always agree well then they should
be made to something awful lot like a
dictatorship to me well if it works and
this isn't just true of Zhivago and
anakin in Doctor Zhivago
Lara marries a revolutionary but after
being forced to flee those same
revolutionaries she ends up saying this
is an awful time to be alive her
loyalties shift
whereas Padme believes in democracy at
the beginning of Star Wars and still
does by the end largely because the
movie tells her to Davi stop believing
democracy can work is the day we lose it
let's pray that day never comes
the biggest change she undergoes is to
confess she loves Anakin after having
resisted the relationship through the
whole movie
I shouldn't have done that it'll take us
to a place we cannot go regardless of
the way we feel about each other and
even then that change of heart is only
because I think I think that would be
destroyed anyway how romantic
while Padme shows some signs of
resistance I do not like this idea of
hiding she still shows little agency in
her decisions if she makes any at all
but surely in a movie that ends with war
the politics must have some bearing on
the character arcs right well not really
Doctor Zhivago succeeds in exploring the
complexities of relationships at a time
of war because it shows us the moral
ambiguity of that time the whole first
hour is about setting up oligarchs like
Lara's employer to be heartless monsters
only for the idealistic revolutionaries
like Laura's husband to become equally
heartless Laura and Jeeva go are caught
in the middle of these blurred
distinctions laura dines and dances with
her creepy oligarch employer Komarovsky
at a fancy club but when she meets up
with her wide-eyed idealist
husband-to-be Pasha a few scenes later
he says this is where the pigs were
eating and drinking and dancing
not knowing Laura was there at the end
of the movies Avago must accept Kamarov
skis help to save Laura Eastman that
came with me today as an escort come for
her and the child tomorrow as a firing
squad
a man who earlier rapes Laura and then
was shot by her
wounds Avago is asked to heal these are
the kinds of complexities and confused
loyalties that life in a time of
conflict creates complexities that don't
really exist an attack of the clones for
example where Doctor Zhivago has the
character of Pasha a political protester
turned tyrannical commander Attack of
the Clones has Count Dooku a former Jedi
turned traitor to the Republic both
characters are depicted in similar ways
Pasha who becomes the commander of the
Red Army changes his name to strelnikov
and Count Dooku changes his name to
Tyrannis they are both either shown or
explained to be idealists at the start
Dooku is referred to within the first
five minutes of the movie as is a
political idealist not a murderer you
know milady Count Dooku was once a Jedi
he couldn't assassinate anyone it's not
in his character while we're introduced
to Pasha handing out flyers to workers
for a protest the problem is how we see
these characters change and develop over
the course of the movie we think Pasha
is killed in the trenches of World War
one only for his reveal a strelnikov to
be the shocked twist that concludes the
first half of the movie we knew his
allegiances before the war and it makes
sense that he would make his way up the
ranks of the Bolshevik army it's a twist
because we thought he was dead not
because his motivations changed there is
no revelation or even catharsis an
attack of the clones the next time we
hear anything about Dooku after his
passing mention at the start is over
halfway through when he appears and
basically explains his entire conspiracy
while obi-wan is an earshot after that
he tries to convince oh we want to join
his cause by pretending to be on his
side oh no my right
this is a mistake a terrible mistake
they've gone too far is it met this
would have been a great opportunity to
develop his character more if he had
been introduced earlier it could show
some conflict about his ideals
maybe then obi-wan would sympathize with
him but no the next minute Dooku
sentences them all to death chops off
Anakin's arm and delivers the death star
plans to Darth Sidious no such moral
ambiguity there other than a few
sentences from nameless characters at
the start the audience has given no
reason to care about Duke whose
treachery or where his loyalties lie a
lot of these problems can be traced back
to the same script issues episode one
had whether it's the threat of Padma's
life being sent to Naboo obi-wan
stumbling across the Clone Army or a
declaration of war all this happens to
the characters not because of the
characters in fact the most significant
decision of the whole movie is done off
screen by Jar Jar who decides to grant
the Chancellor executive powers this
choice shapes the fate of the galaxy but
the most we see of his decision-making
process is a shot of him looking pensive
episode twos biggest flaw though is the
romance itself
where's Avago and Lara's love is
tortured and forbidden but ultimately
feels true Anakin and Padme is meant to
be all those things but we're never
really given any reason to believe that
these vago Falls for a woman who shares
his compassion while Lara Falls for a
good man of great talent and character
whom she admires meanwhile across the
galaxy a moody teenager inexplicably
wins over a much older woman by being
really my goodness you've got some of
you beautifully really I don't think she
liked me watching really the thought of
not being with you I can't breathe
really creepy not only that the
forbidden nature of their romance
doesn't seem all that forbidden though
we're repeatedly told it's wrong you're
studying to become a Jedi I'm I'm a
senator we're not really shown any
drawbacks and it can even explains a
loophole compassion
I would define as unconditional love
central to a Jedi's life so you might
say that we are encouraged to love and
though obi-wan says Anakin has made a
commitment to the Jedi Order he also
says you have made a commitment to the
Jedi Order a commitment not easily
broken so wait it's not easy but can be
broken that and Anakin and Padme don't
seem all that shy about hiding it when
they make out in front of an arena full
of people including obi-wan their
relationship is discouraged but not
forbidden and they don't seem to love
each other because they admire one
another's characters political beliefs
or talents like Zhivago and Lara may
love each other because the script tells
them to in the end attack of the clones
fails because of its ambitions by trying
to make the movie a cautionary political
drama and epic romance a conspiracy
thriller a mystery and a war movie Lucas
gives himself too much ground to cover
in two hours and as a result he doesn't
integrate these pieces well enough to
give them time enough to develop time
that dr. Zhivago has in spades with it's
three hours and 20 minute running time
and while taking some surface pointers
from a cinema classic is admirable it
fails to deliver on all those key
elements that made the original so great
all right I get the picture but what do
you think wisecrack is it a
misunderstood masterpiece or do you hate
it as much as anakin hates and let us
know in the comments and thanks to all
our patrons who support the channel and
our podcast be sure to hit that
subscribe button and before you go I
want to give a shout out to this week's
sponsor the Rijksmuseum their YouTube
channel Reich's Tube just started a new
series called is this art which explores
pop culture by referencing and exploring
the history of art longtime wisecrack
viewers know we're all about making
learning entertaining and accessible so
I'm really happy to be working with them
and support their mission Rijksmuseum is
one of the most renowned museums in the
world and now they have a channel so
even if you're not in Amsterdam you can
check out some awesome content they've
got a great video on how meme culture
isn't all that different from classical
art and another that tais-toi collection
to the history of dollhouses it's all
really awesome and will help you think
of pop culture in a whole new way check
out their latest video by clicking here
and make sure to subscribe and tell them
that wisecrack sent you and as always
thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]